là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ni non
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée les valises à paris
qu'est ce qui lui arrive à la bulle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'inattendu l'émission qui décrypte
l'actualité grâce aux archives de la
télévision aujourd'hui notre journal de
campagne s'intéresse au slogan des
présidentielles puis nous parlerons fait
divers un la sphère grégory xavier
dupont de ligonnès ou encore nordahl le
landais des dossiers particulièrement
médiatisé existe-t-il une appétence
particulière en france pour les faits
divers nous posons la question à
dominique verdeilhan ex chroniqueur
judiciaire de france télévisions il est
notre invité mais d'abord notre revue de
presse avec géraldine corner lavaud et
camille d'auxerre journaliste à la
rédaction de l'ina alors je vous
géraldine c'est une étude sortie en
début de semaine qui vous a interpellé
les français passent de plus en plus de
temps devant leur écran qu'est-ce qui se
passe et oui 1 44% des z ville vous êtes
vous en faites peut-être partie 53 % des
enfants déclarent avoir passé plus de
temps sur les écrans quand 2019 alors
c'est sûrement une faute au confinement
les cours via internet les visio avec
mappy et mamie évidemment aujourd'hui
les écrans sont multiples on a les
smartphones on a les tablettes les
ordinateurs la télé alors dans les
années 70 il n'y avait que la télé et
pourtant elle était déjà dans la famille
[Musique]
et
jusqu'au bout la après j'ai jugé à oui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est rare que
je vais dire mais malgré tout c'est très
rare
avec le travail le travail est fini vers
votre étau elles soient les hommes
devant
[Musique]
les enfants sont ils sont là une salle
trop fait et ils se disputent ma tante a
fini son travail est là c'est pas pour
faire mieux bon alors ce n'était pas
très rigolo
c'est vrai j'étais obligé de calmer les
enfants de leur donner du papier enfin
des crayons pour essayer de se distraire
ou quoi comme on pouvait
mais se redresse ça ne vient pas c'est
la cata en voisin dors pas toujours
alors maintenant qui la télévision le
petit adore la télévision non à la
télévision bon et quand c'est le film
demandé un moment et quand c'est le film
celui là n'est pas parce que je sais il
restera jusqu'à vendredi soir et
j'adore j'adore l'ambiance qui règne
dans ce reportage
les habits tout ça c'est génial et en
plus on peut même pas en vouloir à nos
enfants de regarder la télévision les
portables parce que je pense que parmi
nous on les regarde peut-être un petit
peu plus longtemps voilà c'est tout
autre chose dans quelques jours camille
way la saint valentin est la fête des
amoureux
mais c'est surtout un mauvais moment à
passer pour tous les célibataires pour
eux pas de cadeaux pas de croissants au
réveil pas de roses rouges déposé comme
ça sur la table quand on rentre le soir
et bien non il
est bien dans les années 70 ce n'était
pas les amoureux qui faisait la fête
mais bien les célibataires ils se
retrouvaient dans des foires aux
célibataires où ils venaient chercher
leurs moitiés les diverses demandes sont
affichées et les candidats au mariage
peuvent étudier en toute quiétude les
propositions parmi lesquelles peut-être
celle de leur futur conjoint qu'est ce
que vous reprochez la connaissance et du
batteur
on n'a pas été émis sans la terre pour
acheter salle n'ai jamais eu de femme
jamais connu
savons donc pas et si vous trouvez une
femme cette année vous épouser rhm
combien oui j'ai jamais dit non et
blondes brunes oh vous savez la nuit ça
paraît pas la couleur
et utilité attendez-vous d'elle bonne
cuisinière surtout est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est sérieux
alors vous espérez trouver un mari
[Musique]
hier à saint denis du payré 79 hommes se
sont inscrits pour le mariage il n'y
avait que 28 femmes décidément il y aura
toujours des gains à marier la barre
[Musique]
pour toujours des gamins je vais vous
dire ce lundi exactement mais il ya
aussi des femmes en france plus d'une
personne sur cinq entre 25 et 65 ans et
célibataire selon l'insee alors c'est un
chiffre de 2013 je n'ai pas trouvé plus
récents mais je me suis dit que ça
laisser un peu d'espoir à tous les
célibataires chalet du monde pour faire
une grosse fête surtout la
saint-valentin mode d'emploi merci
beaucoup camille voilà pour l'actualité
de cette semaine alors que s'est il
passé à cette même période de l'année
par le passé mais pour le savoir il vous
suffit de regarder le zapping de
l'inattendu
bonjour
vous ne verrez pas laurent fabius
georgina dufoix ou edmond hervé ils ont
choisi de ne pas être filmés devant
leurs pairs et juge
lorsqu'il entre le président le gunehec
l'a donc pas admis que les témoins cette
plainte retenu sept victimes qui pour la
première fois dans quelques minutes
seront pas sa phase avec les ministres
face à face deux monstres l'un kasparov
ne supporte pas la défaite l'autre n'est
pas vraiment conçu pour perdre cet
ordinateur dispose en effet d'une base
de données qui répertorie toutes les
parties jouées au 20e siècle et kasparov
a juré de lui faire mordre la poussière
de nombreux ministres et anciens
ministres était là ce matin sur le quai
de l'hôtel de ville rendant un nouvel
hommage à celui qui fut le président des
français ce traité vise je vous le
rappelle à la mise en place progressive
d'une union économique d'une monnaie
unique et d'une politique étrangère
susceptible de conduire à une défense
commune européenne
l'honneur de remettre demain
ce sera une grande date dans notre
histoire sociale comme tout bon thriller
monsieur giscard d'estaing fait parfois
une chute mais soyons juste celle ci est
de notre faute
[Musique]
au départ
à bilbao
[Musique]
bonsoir
notre rendez vous politique maintenant
pendant quelques semaines on va
s'intéresser à la campagne
présidentielle nous aussi géraldine
aujourd'hui on va parler des slogans
électoraux oui un chaque candidat à son
slogan qui doit s'il faut le rappeler un
résumé son programme résumé sa
philosophie mais aussi le slogan doit
mobiliser fédérer les électeurs c'est un
incontournable de la campagne il doit se
vendre il doit se vendre alors on va
commencer cette chronique avec un petit
jeu je sais que vous l'attendez alors je
vais vous dire des slogans de 2022 et
vous allez devoir deviner à quel
candidat ce slogan appartient vous êtes
prêts ok c'est parti la france des jours
heureux fabien roussel un point en
maternelle on continue alors rendre aux
français leur argent avec une variante
rendre aux français leur pays marine le
pen marine le pen un point pour cammy
effectivement un slogan d'ailleurs
qu'elle a changé et durcit suite à la
montée d'eric zemmour dans les sondages
c'est à noter eric zemmour d'ailleurs
une idée de son slogan impossible n'est
pas français impossible n'est pas
français 2 point pour cammy doucement
avec la table
impossible n'est pas français on note
évidemment la référence à napoléon bien
sûr alors une dernière pas facile celle
ci le courage de dire la volonté de fer
elle a déjà été utilisé en 1988 par les
verts pour les élections les élections
législatives et mot pour mot par le
front national en 1993 aussi pour des
élections législatives et donc en 2022
qui a encore une fois réutiliser selon
pascal et copyrights comme ça sur les
slogans non ya pas de copenhague arlette
laguiller non
eh ben c'est valérie pécresse pour les
républicains le courage de dire la
volonté de faire voilà on peut le voir
avec une valérie pécresse qui ressemble
étrangement à marianne est bien calculé
on pourrait aussi citer l'avenir en
commun de jean luc mélenchon réunir la
france d'anne hidalgo changeant la
france pour vivre mieux de yannick jadot
il y en a encore plein d'autres mais
quid des slogans des précédentes
élections présidentielles voici un petit
florilège de différents slogans des
campagnes génération 1030 la france unie
lionel jospin c'est clair trois rouleaux
france le président du vrai changement
bat france lui-même le changement c'est
maintenant depuis le début de la vème
république les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ont un slogan en une
phrase le candidat doit symboliser tout
son programme un sacré défi car à peine
dévoilé les slogans sont étudiées
critiquer on voit des formules creuses
les formes sèches des formules qui ne
déclenche absolument aucune émotion
bah quand j'entends villiers ses neuf
moi j'entends ces très vieux c'est du
slogan de d'avant la deuxième guerre
mondiale moi quand j'entends le pen
président c'est pas ça qui va me
déclenchée en fait on a des formules qui
sont très sa piste et qui reflète une
une vision réductrice de l'électorat et
parfois les tacles ce fonds au sein même
des partis comme ici en 1995 au ps c'est
vrai que c'est pas trés forcément très
chaleureux même si je pense que le verre
d'eau si un peu l'image mais c'est vrai
c'est une affiche assez académique
conventionnel
pas simple de trouver la bonne formule
alors parfois des candidats font le
choix de ne pas avoir de slogans mais
c'est sans compter sur leurs militants
le seul à avoir gagné une campagne sans
slogan officiel c'est valéry giscard
d'estaing en 74 mais la nature ayant
horreur du vide ces militants avaient
trouvé
les années passent les campagnes se
succèdent et le champ lexical des
slogans lui reste assez restreint on
retrouve très souvent les mêmes mots la
france la force nouvelle courage alors
forcément parfois ça cafouille jeu
chouette fernet la nouvelle france dont
ce début de siècle apporte la promesse
nouvelle france où france nouvelle le
concept lui n'a rien de nouveau il y a
quelques jours dans la bouche de lionel
jospin il y a quelques mois sous la
plume d'alain madelin le président de
démocratie libérale l'a déjà utilisé au
lancement de sa campagne le 2 avril
dernier il en revendique la paternité
la guerre est féroce car plus les
campagnes sont médiatisés plus le slogan
outils de communication sans pareil
devient cruciale alors depuis quelques
années dévoilé son slogan c'est le top
départ de la campagne nouveau slogan qui
apparaît sur un écran géant ségolène
royal voulait soigner son public le ps
lui a soigné la mise en scène
mais il ya un slogan qui a vraiment
marqué les esprits et qui a mené son
candidat vers la victoire c'est la force
tranquille de françois mitterrand en
derrière cette formule jacques séguéla
la force tranquille on s'en souvient
tous de cette fable de nous en parler
j'étais venu vous en parlez de voir
comment ça a été ça avait mûri dans sa
tête on se dit que tout le monde la
connaît ou presque en 2012 c'est assez
drôle des journalistes de france 2 était
allé interroger des étudiants en
sciences po pour savoir le même quiz
s'il arrivait à
réunir le slogan est le bon candidat
regardez ce n'était pas vraiment ça
mitterrand s'était pas d'accord non
c'était la campagne tranquillement
s'était passé a annoncé qu il avait
tranquille est restée la campagne 30e la
force tranquille de françois mitterrand
et en 88 françois mitterrand
je n'ai plus la france unie et jacques
chirac en 95
mangez des pommes on s'était passé et
non c'était la france pour tous
mangez des pommes on le dit quand même
c'était la parodie des guignols et les
gens se souviennent plus de cette
parodie que du vrai slogan merci
beaucoup on n'imagine pas tout ce qui se
passe derrière un slogan voilà on les
regardera différemment maintenant merci
j'ai déjà fait
[Musique]
et dominique verdeilhan est l'invité de
l'inattendu bonjour dominique vous avez
couvert l'actualité judiciaire pour
france télévisions pendant pendant un
petit peu plus de trente ans vous avez
d'ailleurs publié il ya quelques mois
l'audience est ouverte chronique d'une
justice défaillante c'est aux éditions
du rocher alors en ce moment nordahl le
landais comparaît devant les assises
pour le meurtre de la petite maelys
c'était en août 2017 250 journalistes
sont accrédités pour suivre ce procès
qu'est ce qui fait qu'à un fait divers
attire plus qu'un autre ce n'est pas
toujours d'explication
évidemment là c'est c'est l'horreur
parce qu'on s'attaque à un enfant et à
chaque fois qu'on s'attaque à un enfant
évidemment on s'identifie à ses parents
et on veut comprendre quelles peuvent
être les motivations de celui qui a
commis sa on veut voir
la tête du monstre camille il a fallu
faire un choix entre tous les faits
divers le premier à être médiatisé
arrêté l'essai la sphère dominicis
c'était dans les années 50 oui
absolument gaston dominici ce vieux
paysan que vous voyez justement accusé
donc d'un triple meurtre un couple
d'anglais et leur petite fille de 10 ans
c'était en août
1952 et très vite dans les médias et
bien c'est simple il est coupable et le
doute n'est pas permis
[Musique]
voici l'assassin gaston dominici le
grand père a avoué son crime
la veille encore malgré les dénégations
forcené des femmes de la famille qui a
injurié les enquêteurs sa culpabilité ne
faisait plus de doute
alors voici là ça sent la présomption d
or soit l'avant sa culpabilité ne
faisait plus de doute alors certes
dominici avait avoué mais ensuite il
s'est rétracté il a clamé son innocence
dans les années 50 on voit les
journalistes avaient une notion toute
particulière justement de cette
présomption d'innocence oui il fallait
faire monter un peu la tension c'est
cette famille de paysans un petit peu un
peu fruste requis qui est mis en
accusation alors avec cette personnalité
de gaston de sa femme qu'on appelle la
sardine les deux enfants qui vont
accuser qui vont se rétracter enfin
voilà sire que comme on dit vous écrivez
ça scénario on vous dit vous en faites
trop sauf que là c'est la réalité donc
deux ans plus tard il ya le procès qui
se passe en 1954 des journalistes du
monde entier se pressent dans la petite
salle du tribunal de digne
l'afer qui hante tous les esprits et que
suivre minute par minute 120
journalistes avec leurs caméras leur
téléscripteur et leurs baleineaux
l'une des plus grandes affaires du
siècle touche à sa fin c'est maintenant
l'heure du verdict
il ya même la musique il pourrait plus
parler on pourrait plus parler comme ça
est-ce que vous connaissiez ces images
ce qui est étonnant avec le procès
dominicis c'est qu'on a jamais plus vu
ensuite tous ces attroupements dans ses
salles d'audience non parce qu'il ya une
explication on l'a entendu il ya 150
journalistes les photographes les
cameramen sont encore autorisés à mettre
dans la salle sauf que ça crée ça
perturbe totalement l'audience est ce
qui fait que le président des assises
monsieur bout ce qu'elle va dire à
l'issue de ce procès côté c'est plus
possible il ya une décision qui est
prise très rapidement pas le président
du conseil enfin 54 début 55 qui
consiste à dire les procès ne pourront
plus être filmés ça veut dire caméra
journaliste dehors et c'est depuis que
nous sommes là et dire dans les couloirs
elle heureusement la législation là
dessus a changé puisqu'on va ouvrir à
nouveau les salles d'audience des procès
vont être filmé les émissions de
télévision vont être faisable maintenant
oui parce qu'il faut aussi montrer
comment la justice fonctionne on va
continuer à remonter le temps judiciaire
à quelques années plus tard un autre
fait divers camille fait l'ouverture des
jt oui et c'est peu dire la france a
peur c'est roger gicquel au 20 heures de
tf1 le 18 février 1976 la france a peur
pourquoi parce qu'un enfant a été tué
c'est la sphère patrick henry
tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
ont soir
la france a peur je crois qu'on peut le
dire aussi nettement la france connaît
la panique depuis qu'hier soir une
vingtaine de minutes après la fin de ce
journal on lui a appris cette horreur un
enfant est mort un 12 enfants au regard
profond assassiné étranglé ou étouffé on
ne sait pas encore le top 6 ne l'a pas
complètement révélé par le monstre qui
l'avait enlevée pour de l'argent oui la
france a peur et nous avons peur et
c'est un sentiment qu'il faut déjà que
nous combattions je crois alors ce qu'on
vient de voir fait quarante secondes
mais en tout roger gicquel va consacrer
vente et une minute à la faire contre 6
minutes pour les autres faits
d'actualité comment vous l'expliquez est
ce que c'est parce que déjà dans les
années soixante dix les français adorent
les faits divers seront se passionne
pour ça ou parce que c'est cette affaire
particulière qui relance notamment le
débat sur la peine de mort dans le pays
est à la fois des deux ça tient aussi
peut-être de la personnalité de de roger
gicquel sire que la en aidant dans
l'éditorial est ce qu'aujourd'hui à
présentateur de 20 heures quelle que
soit la chaîne irait jusqu'à dire la
france a peur je suis pas sûr que le
rédacteur en chef lui dirai coco tu vas
peut-être un petit peu loin allons
d'abord dans le factuel tout le monde
dans le pays réagi avec émotion y
compris roger gicquel qui en
1998 de 20 ans après revenez sur ce
qu'il avait dit à l'antenne il y à une
émotion
nationale qui vient des médias mais que
les politiques n'ont pas maîtrisé ils se
sont emparés de philo se sont servis de
cette émotion ils ont dit l'un plusieurs
ministres ont dit faut le condamner à
mort tout de suite sans jugement c'est à
partir de là j'ai dit la france a peur
et en plus on lui vend lui ful affronte
ses héros fait cette contrainte d'y
participer aussi moi j'aimerais savoir
si vous dans votre carrière vous avez
déjà été pris par l'émotion en couvrant
une affaire oui on comme je dis on ne
sort pas indemne d'une affaire
judiciaire donc que ce soit au moment de
l'investigation mais encore plus quand
vous êtes à un procès parce qu'un procès
c'est c'est une sorte de huis clos et et
tout se dit donc vous ne pouvez pas
rester insensible à quelquefois
effectivement à une déposition d'un
témoin aux cris d' une victime voilà
après la difficulté qu'on soit
journalistes presse écrite de radio et
de télévision c'est évidemment au moment
où on fait le papier de de prendre du
recul
j'ai essayé de le faire pendant trente
trois ans mais très souvent après avoir
fini mon papier je ne cache pas que j'ai
versé quelques larmes il ya aussi les
ratés journalistique un camille ratés
collectifs lors de faits divers ou
ratées journalistique de la police de la
justice tout le monde le cas d'école l'
affaire grégory donc on est en
1984 le corps de ce petit garçon de 4
ans est retrouvé dans la vologne dans
les vosges et alors là c'est le début
d'un fait divers qui va passionner toute
la france et qui passionne encore et
dans lequel les journalistes se sont
plongés forcément la tête la première
neuf ans après les faits dans le journal
de france 2 un journaliste revenait
justement sur le traitement médiatique
de cette affaire dominique verdeilhan
une affaire qui remonte déjà à 9 ans
mais que la presse n'a jamais cessé de
traiter en long et en large
isabelle stress et dominique verdeilhan
récit le vent durant lesquelles tout a
été dit vu entendu enregistré
photographier premières photos celles
prises par un photographe de presse
locale le corps de grégory flottant dans
la vologne la vallée de la vologne
devient soudain le centre du monde
médiatique les gendarmes sont bavards
les conférences de presse quotidiennes
pas un mouvement des enquêteurs
n'échappe à la presse la collaboration
est étroite parfois trop si jamais vous
pouvez nous aider ce sera bien accueilli
appel à moitié entendu oui la presse va
participer à l' enquête jusqu'à créer
deux clans les pros villemin et les pros
la roche non la presse ne va pas prendre
ses distances incompatibilité entre deux
notions le droit et le devoir d'informer
et le secret de l'instruction
l' affaire grégory ou l'instruction
après sous verre
une instruction après sous verre ce sont
vos mots dominique verdeilhan est-ce qui
vous voulez maintenant je les maintiens
gps qui vous a marqué ce traitement
journalistique de l' affaire grégory
c'est fou quand on entend même ce
commandant dire aux journalistes auront
aidés nous oui vous l'avez dit c'est un
dérapage collectif et puis comme
effectivement il ya un vide du côté de
la justice parce que ces affaires-là
vous savez elles sont elles sont résolus
dans les jours ou dans les semaines qui
suivent le crime où elle s'en est la
preuve puisque on est quoi 37 ans 38 ans
après et on n'a toujours pas la solution
est donc à ce moment là bas se vident
judiciaire il est rempli par le vide
médiatique c'est la course au scoop donc
à partir du moment où c'est la course au
scoop vous ne retenez pas votre stylo
vous ne retenez pas votre parole et et
vous y allez on va s'intéresser à un
fait divers dominique à un fait divers
dont vous avez suivi le procès c'était à
la motte du caire on va d'ailleurs vous
voir tenez c'est vous dominique devant
le tribunal oui le ce fait divers c'est
le meurtre et le viol d'une petite fille
de 6 ans émile jourdan dans les alpes de
haute provence en
1988 cette affaire elle avait ému la
france entière comme un peu la sphère
maylis aujourd'hui deux hommes sont
accusés didier gentil richard roman et
la presse les condamne la machine
judiciaire soit on s'emballe se met en
route des violences vont même éclaté
pendant la reconstitution et on voit
l'avocat henri leclerc ressort justement
de cette reconstitution sont chemise
ensanglantée et celui qui va approuver
la probable innocence de richard roman
et bien c'est un journaliste ce que j'ai
découvert en enquêtant sur place c'est
que les deux hommes qui sont aujourd'hui
en prison suspecté d'avoir assassiné
céline ne se sont pas rencontrés le soir
où l'enfant est assassiné j'essaie de
reconstituer à la minute près
les horaires ce soir-là de chacun des
deux hommes
est le fait qu'ils ne se sont pas
rencontrés montre de toute évidence qui
en a un qui n'étaient pas là et qui en a
1 donc qui à mon sens est innocent et
c'est richard roman est ce que cette
affaire c'est l'exemple parfait du
mélange des genres entre jours liszt et
policiers c'est un mélange des genres
d'abord je dis souvent il ya quand même
un point commun entre la justice et la
presse c'est le mot enquête donc il ya
des enquêtes journalistiques et des
enquêtes judiciaires c'est plutôt
j'allais dire le bon exemple le contre
exemple on a vu la presse qui perturbe
dans la sphère grégory et puis de temps
en temps il ya la presse qui aide la
justice souvenons nous que dans la
sphère la mode du caire pendant que
l'événement du jeudi plaidait j'allais
dire la cause de richard roman un autre
magazine lui faisait 1,3615 que dans dix
ans est-ce que d'après vous il est
coupable ou pas voilà donc
une fois qu'on a dit ça il ya plusieurs
justice et il ya plusieurs médias voilà
les faits divers une passion française
avec dominique verdeilhan merci bien
vouloir de nous avoir éclairé sur ce
sujet et merci à vous camille pour avoir
réuni toutes ses archives absolument
absolument incroyable on se quitte avec
notre traditionnel pépites à tous les
candidats à la présidentielle vont la
chanter au moins une fois dans les
prochaines semaines dans leurs meetings
c'est la marseillaise et on a trouvé
dans les archives celui qui a sans doute
le mieux chanter cette marseillaise
c'était raymond barre en
[Musique]
bonjour
mon grand amour
non
enfants
[Musique]
à
aussillon
voilà pour tout vous dire je ne ferai
certainement pas mieux on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine sur le canal 27 en
attendant sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit ce dina où cette france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes viviane barney emilie
galtier merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là comme chaque semaine
[Musique]